plenty of people traveled up to lee
canyon and mount charleston looking for
a christmas of white madison kimbrough
was one of them she is live now with why
being prepared is key when you're going
up madison
yeah lots of people excited for the snow
and the activities but because of the
icy conditions a lot of people did not
bring the proper gear and had to be
redirected
we cannot go up there because we don't
have the
the chain for the tires it's a snow day
here in mount charleston as people
celebrating the christmas holiday came
out ready to have some fun out on the
ice
some came prepared while others who
didn't have snow chains or four-wheel
drive had to take an alternate route
we're putting snow chains on since
they're required even though we have
four-wheel drive to be safe so sorry
that you are required to have the chains
which i don't have right now
even so many say they knew they wouldn't
be able to get past a certain point and
just wanted to drive up and enjoy the
scenic views oh i knew that coming up we
were up here once before
it was a year ago
and
there was more snow way down there the
first time for my kids to come over
yeah and they are excited you know to
you know to see snow we'll pay attention
to safety and we'll be very careful we
were told that lee canyon had a good
turnout as well for those who wanted to
go skiing or snowboarding currently they
are prepping to open their larger hill
only the bunny hill is open now and for
those missing the mount charleston lodge
this year many chose to stop at the
resort nearby for food and hot drinks on
their way up
now again this weekend is expected to be
busier than today so make sure that when
you drive your vehicle up it's a vehicle
that can actually make it up there
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now